we thank you very much for being here in
the wild on mr. Pfeiffer is getting
similarly hooked up but let me thank you
for being with us tonight it was noted
earlier that mr. Tuerck ashen is not
feeling well we will be speaking with
him by telephone and try to get some
more insight into some of the remarkable
things that have come out in this book
spy handler to say that it advances the
stories of Aldrich Ames and Robert
Hansen would be an understatement as
well as other names as well
Chernov Skee Pelton a host of people
players if you will in this remarkable
game and I suppose that's really what it
is at the core a game with incredible
stakes and consequences but a game for
these people nonetheless mr. Pfeifer I
guess we should start out by just noting
a little beat brief a background of
Victor check-cashing a man who in a way
joined the family business that's right
his father was an officer in the NKVD
which was a predecessor to the KGB
so he really did grow up in the business
his family had to flee though the
eastern front of World War 2 when the
Nazis attacked the Soviet Union and his
father he was separated from his father
his mother and two brothers and his
sister fled to various places including
Kazakhstan but his father was posted in
Stalingrad and Victor went to Stalingrad
was reunited with his father after the
worst fighting was over there and he saw
the carnage saw the effects of that's a
terrible battle there and so it's yeah I
mean right from the beginning has
fascinating fascinating story to tell
the central story is of course in the
book center around Aldrich Ames and
Robert Hanson I will start out here with
something from page 4 of the paperback
various sums have been reported about
how much Ames was paid we considered his
efforts worth every penny of the 2.7
million dollars he was actually
allocated what else in here
would be something that we don't know
about all rejects well we probably don't
know a lot and there's also probably we
won't know a lot ever won one of the oh
one of the things about the Espionage
business is that it's highly
compartmentalized victor recruited and
ran Aldrich Ames in 1985 until he left
Washington for Russia in 1986 what
happened after Victor wasn't privy to
that information
he was just kept out of it so whereas he
knows how how Ames signed up with the
KGB and how he started giving over the
really damaging information that he did
because Victor himself worked hard on
Ames to convince him to give over his
intelligence that he knows but as far as
the whole picture it's something that
will have to come out over the years are
you right here the CIA didn't recognize
fought hid it and still doesn't to this
day but really took place in Chadwicks
restaurant in Washington on the
riverfront K Street is known only to the
three principals what have you learned
about what took place at that meeting
involving all regimes well I learned and
readers of the book will learn that
until that meeting in June of 1985
Aldrich Ames had really approached the
KGB with information that he didn't
think was very useful essentially he
approached approached the Washington KGB
station first with the the names of two
double agents that is KGB intelligence
officers who purported to work for the
CIA but really were working for the KGB
all along passing on misinformation and
Victor worked on Ames telling him that
the KGB couldn't provide for his
security couldn't couldn't stop any
possible CIA mole
in the KGB from betraying him unless it
near the names of these people and it
really victor played on that and God
aims to take out a piece of paper and
write down a list of some of the CIA's
top agents and some of its top
operations in North right here then
began the second chapter of Eames spy
career he hesitated but took out a
notepad and paper and began writing down
a list of names he tore out the page and
handed it to me victor cherkashin
I was shocked the paper contained more
information about CIA espionage and had
ever before been presented in a single
communication and this section here
about three pages in the paperback
edition sure cache and plays aims like a
Scrat of various I mean it is just
remarkable that's right well it's the
nature of the Espionage business I think
Victor is a very good student of human
nature and certainly had to exploit it
during his career to try to recruit
agents and there several factors that I
mean Victor did recruit Hansen Robert
Hansen and Aldrich Ames but he
essentially said I mean it's true that
both of them had made up their minds to
spy before approaching the KGB and it's
a process of knowing exactly what
they're willing to give over and working
working on that and someone who is as
good at this as obviously Turkish and
turned out to be has thoughts about
general ideas of motivation and I found
this most interesting ideology very
rarely if ever motivates treason
personal reasons usually prevail and
ideological justifications often come
after a decision to commit treason has
been made for those much more private
and immediate motivations it would seem
in the case of these two principles here
was primarily money wouldn't it well for
Ames it was it was primarily money
certainly but there were other issues
too
Ames was disgruntled he was wasn't
exactly happy with the CIA
he felt that the agency was overstating
Soviet military capacity and Soviet
economic strength in order to well
generate more funds for the agency and
he was unhappy with this so there it's
it's rarely just one reason certainly
there are agents that come approach the
KGB and said you know I'm in it for the
money but Victor says almost always that
agents say I'm I'm in it for world peace
that I just want the Soviet Union and
the United States to get along and of
course he says that's that's almost
never the reason it's always used as
justification after the fact
chapter age Washington station how to
catch us by October 1985 Dirk ashen gets
the day's cables included is an envelope
which was marked do not open and it said
take this envelope unopened to victory
chair cache and that was the envelope
inside an outer envelope that was
delivered to the apartment of a
mid-level intelligence officer the
letter inside starts at dear mr. Turk
ashen soon I will send a box of
documents to this mid-level official
they are from certain of the most
sensitive and highly compartmented
projects the US intelligence community
has all our originals to aid in
verifying their authenticity please
recognize for our long-term interests
that there are a limited number of
persons with this array of clearances as
a collector they a collection rather
they point to me and the first thing
that goes through your conscious mind is
too good to be true is this a trap well
absolutely and certainly when an agent
or would be agent approaches approach
the KGB or and any agency one of the
first thoughts if not the first thought
is that this very well may be a double
agent sent to spread disinformation
certainly that was the case with Robert
Hansen because he sent this letter
barely six months after Victor had
recruited Ames so just names alone is a
remarkable success
in any intelligence officers career to
have two people like this is quite
unbelievable and I don't think he
believes it at first who did the most
damage Eames I think that at the end of
the day Robert Hansen did more damage to
our national security he betrayed spy
satellite of programs uh most of them
run by the NSA so he's essentially
called the most damaging spy American
spy Robert Hanssen is called the
deadliest because he gave over the names
of many agents ten of whom were executed
or at least 10 10 that we know of so
it's really I think difficult to say the
intelligence that Ames gave to the KGB
allowed the Soviets to wrap up basically
every agent and operation that the CIA
was running in the Soviet Union so that
when the Soviet Union came crumbling
down actually even before that with in
1989 with the fall of the essentially
the crumbling of the Soviet bloc the CIA
was getting its a lot of its information
from CNN simply because they didn't have
assets on the ground that's that's
remarkable we will be coming up shortly
at the point at which I understand we'll
be taking this phone call and I must
confess I'm not sure of the status of
that so you'll have to let me know
is mr. Trek hash and standing by well
someone is okay we'll then we'll
okay very good I just wanted to be sure
that that he was there another name that
comes up here jerk ashen again gets the
message he says his name's Ronald Pelton
and he was fired from the NSA last year
he's willing to give us information he
thinks we'll find very interesting he
says he wants money
well that was upfront well that's right
actually Pelton is one of the one of the
cases that he came and he wanted the
money he was in it for the money
he was the guy was he not who who
compromised the tapping of the Soviet
communications cable in the Pacific
that's right it was a highly complex
incredible operation I think was run
jointly by the CIA and the NSA to tap an
underwater cable in the sea of a horse
running out of the Vladivostok in the
Far East and it was a it was a tap
placed on the cable by submarine and
some American submarines would
especially outfitted would have to
return periodically to replace the tapes
and it cost I don't remember exactly but
hundreds of millions of dollars and
Ronald Pelton betrayed the operation was
called Ivy bells for a $35,000 just to
quote from page 116 of spy handler as
long as punishment for espionage remains
as dire as certain imprisonment or he
was usually death in the Soviet Union
spies will have greater motives to
broaden their activities than to come
clean obviously that's not the point of
harsher punishment how does that work
well
Victor's idea is that once of
intelligence officers or anybody else
starts spying just like in the case of
Ames he first approached the KGB with
relatively worthless information then he
became very concerned about his own
security there were arrests of
they're Soviet agents and he started
really worrying for his own safety
his answer essentially was to commit
even more espionage by giving up the
names of these agents who could possibly
betrayed him
I think Victor's point is that if it
were if punishment weren't as severe
perhaps he would have made the decision
to stop altogether with the agents that
he had recruited are compromised in the
books by handler Circassian expresses
what seems like genuine remorse here's a
man obviously prepared to do what he
could in the service of his country but
did you get that same feeling and
talking with him that he was sorry and
not just that the operation was
compromised but sorry for what was
happening to too handsome to Aldrich
Ames his wife was Aereo and so on well
absolutely I think that he felt quite
bad when Aldrich Ames was arrested he
actually suggested that he take in Ames
as I think it was his his son was five
years old at the time and Victor
volunteered to take him in and bring him
up while Ames's in imprisoned so
certainly but four Soviets Aldrich Ames
is a hero in the same way that alia
pinkowski the the well-known American
and British agent who spied against his
own country the Soviet Union he's a hero
to us but a traitor to them so the I
think that that's that's that's pretty
natural to feel that way Robert Hansen
he didn't know
in fact the KGB didn't know who Hansen
was didn't know his name until he was
arrested by the FBI in 2001 so the
feelings warrant is intense I think for
Victor regarding podgorsky here he is
called at one point in the books by
handler the spy who saved the world is
that overstating the case well it's a
matter of debate and certainly there was
I think goes
there was a book written with the title
despite who saved the world and it's
accepted essentially that the
information that Penkovsky gave to the
British and the Americans about Soviet
military capability and the technical
specifications of various missiles
helped President Kennedy make the
decision to stand up against the Soviet
Union during the Cuban Missile Crisis
now the the real extent to which can
cost keys intelligence played a crucial
role is still up for debate certainly
even in course keys CIA handlers at the
time got the sense that he had delusions
of grandeur maybe that's putting it a
little too strongly but something along
those lines
Victor says in the book that can cost
key wanted to put himself in the center
of the Cold War essentially to have the
Americans depend on the intelligence
that he was giving and he was always
warning about imminent nuclear war and I
think he wanted to meet the British
Queen and tell her personally about you
know warn her
so I don't think that there's one right
or wrong interpretation but certainly I
think that all these different different
analyses are valid how did he avoid
walking into traps laid by the CIA mi5
or whomever I think he was very careful
Victor his his his co-workers his
colleagues and the intelligence officers
on the other side and CIA in the FBI all
told me that Victor was a hard worker a
hard driver very exacting and of course
most of intelligence work I don't think
Victor was by any means unique in this
is sitting behind your desk writing
reports but also preparing for
operations it would take months of
painstaking preparations to figure out
meeting places to figure out location
for so-called dead drop dead drops where
money and intelligence material was
exchanged and it took constant thinking
about it Victor says he would go to him
for example go to a museum with his
family and the whole time he'd be
thinking about where would be a good
spot for a dead drop location I was
speaking of as it's put right here in
the book Harebrained Schemes
at one point a Soviet agent in Beirut
came up with a plan to steal a French
built Mirage jet fighter belonging to
the Lebanese military and fly it to
Soviet territory with what ensues reads
like the gang that couldn't spy straight
that's right
well there's there's the the Soviet
officers who staged that were military
intelligence officers the GRU as opposed
to the KGB not treated kindly in this
book no and there's a great rivalry
between the GRU and the KGB and but it
really was it was a harebrained scheme
to steal this Mirage jet and fly it to
fly to the Soviet Union unfortunately
for the Soviet officers the Lebanese
counterintelligence service got wind of
it and I think were pushing them into a
trap all along there was a certain point
they were ambushed by Lebanese soldiers
and one of them was shot both of them
were shot one of them was critically
wounded and it was a yeah it was a
colorful episode and the cold war in
Lebanon before we go to the slide
presentation one more note in that
regard in which you write of the
unspoken agreement that have existed
between intelligence agencies since the
end of World War two that the
adversaries officers would not be
physically harmed was that generally
adhered to oh I think so I think there's
certainly a code of honor our code of
operating that was followed by both
sides certainly if if one side agents
officers were
were hurt why should say officers not
not agents then the other side could
retaliate so there was an unspoken
agreement that intelligence officers
were left unharmed
look spy handler includes some most
interesting pictures and diagrams but we
can actually do better than this
as mr. Pfeiffer will now prove that is
that we have the slide presentation
ready and the Gregory Pfeifer will
narrate this
so this is this is Victor's family
during the war
Victor's on the far left with the hat in
in the front as his mother and then two
brothers and his sister and this is
around the time that they were fleeing
the front to various places during the
Second World War
that's Victor's father the NKVD officer
who was stationed in in Stalingrad and
it was very interesting to me what
Victor thought of his his father but he
told me that he really highly respected
his father he didn't know very much
about what he actually did besides
finding counter revolutionaries but
certainly in his respect for his father
was one of the reasons that he agreed to
go into the service when he was asked to
that is Victor on the far right outside
of the Winter Palace in Leningrad when
he was studying in the KGB Institute
there he it was at that point that he
met
Anya Kalugin the well-known former KGB
officer who now lives in Washington both
of them were studying together in the
Institute and Kalugin went on to become
the first or the youngest KGB general
ever at the age of 43 and have a stellar
career before he denounced the service
and ended up here that's a picture of
the Lubyanka in Moscow which was the old
KGB headquarters very forbidding looking
place in the mid 70s the service moved
out to a suburb of Moscow to a fairly
modern complex but it kept some of its
functions here
that's a picture of a yankovsky the
so-called spy who saved the world this
is a picture of a dead drop location
it's a CIA document a location where
materials were exchanged between the CIA
and Penkovsky Victor was involved in in
helping arrest pinkowski and also
entrapping his CIA handler something
that Penkovsky suggested the KGB do
after his arrest and he was arrested but
released and shortly left the Soviet
Union that is Victor in the middle
obviously to the left is his wife and
there with the wife and children of a
Soviet diplomat that's in Australia
where Victor was first posted abroad he
was there for a couple of years and left
it was it was fairly uneventful his time
there and he left after a soviet KGB
officer defected to the United States
and Victor knew him they knew each other
and there was a possibility that he
could betray betray Victor and so he and
hundreds of other a officers were
recalled from around the world back to
Moscow that is Victor on the right on
the left is REM krasilnikov who was his
superior but that's in Lebanon and
krasilnikov went on to become a real KGB
superstar he was the head of the
internal counterintelligence operating
against Americans in the Soviet Union
precisely at the time that Victor was
handling aims and krasilnikov was back
in Russia
wrapping up the agents arresting the
agents and intercepting the operations
that Ames was betraying that is Victor
on the far right
I like this photograph because of the
shirt in India and this is at a
presentation a sort of diplomatic
presentation of a portrait of Indira
Gandhi by a Soviet artist that is Leonid
shebar Shin also went on to become a
real KGB superstar she Russian and
Victor were both stationed in India and
she Russian and initially they didn't
get along very well because she version
was quite reticent but they ended up
getting along quite well she Russian
went on to become the the head of
foreign intelligence of the KGB and
after the coup the day after the
attempted coup d'etat in 1991 against
Mikhail Gorbachev she version was named
acting KGB chairman for a day was the
shortest KGB chairmanship ever that's
oddly
Kalugin Victor's classmate in the KGB
Institute in Leningrad and went on to
head counterintelligence in the foreign
intelligence Directorate that is of
vladimir krutov who was head of foreign
intelligence in the KGB when Victor was
in in in Washington and chruch Gulf went
on to become KGB chairman and he helped
lead the coup attempt against Gorbachev
in 1991 krutchkov essentially had it in
for Victor because his career was rich
Coast career was facing a dead end
before the recruitment of aims the KGB
had a series of failures
and when Ames was recruited and he
started giving over this devastating
information it was a terrible blow to
the KGB but instead of reporting the the
truth to the Politburo and this is what
what Victor surmises but it's it's it's
it's inaccurate as far as I know instead
of saying well we have this agent and
he's betrayed all these all these moles
in the KGB critical presented this as
successes of the KGB he said that it was
the result of painstaking work by
counterintelligence that these had been
exposed so instead of getting fired
perchik wolf was eventually promoted to
the KGB chairman that's bill Casey the
director of the CIA when when Victor was
in Washington this is diplomat Sergei to
Vulcan who was he wasn't a KGB officer
he was he was a diplomat and he served
as the go-between for Ames and the KGB
in Washington and he actually never knew
it
Victor came up with with a scheme to
pretend that she Vulcan was meeting aims
to as a back-channel communications
between the KGB and Washington this was
to keep the information about Ames as
secret as possible
cheval he never knew this and after the
Soviet collapse I think it was about
sometime in the mid 90s actually it was
after Ames was arrested in 1994 he found
out about this and he was incredibly
angry that all this time he was working
for the KGB without knowing it he was
also I think far from his job as a
diplomat that is Stanislav and Rousseff
who was the Washington resident as the
head of the KGB station was called
he was Victor's boss they got on well
and they worked out a lot of their
operations together that is Sergei
Volkov ski who was actually Eames first
KGB contact when Ames was first dealing
with with the KGB in Washington he was
operating as sensibly as a proper CIA
officer meeting divil Kolski and they
would talk about issues of national
security
DeVoe Koski soon left back for Moscow he
was rotated back and to Vulcan whom we
saw earlier was he replaced him that is
Dmitri Polyakov who was the
highest-ranking American that Ames
betrayed I'm sorry he was the
highest-ranking American agent he was a
general in the military intelligence
Soviet military intelligence who was
codenamed top hat and he was arrested 25
years after he first began spying for
the United States was betrayed by
Aldrich Ames as I said that is Aldrich
Ames some time after his arrest
that is Valeri Martinov who was a an FBI
spy he was a KGB officer Victor at a
certain point new I think in 1984 he
figured out that there was a mole inside
the KGB station here in Washington the
mole turned out to be martin off' and
but it took him many months to figure
out who it was and then after he he did
figure out who it was it took many
months to try to figure out for Victor
to figure out how to get him back to
Moscow without him getting wind of
getting wind of this and fleeing but he
did and March Enif was executed that is
a picture of Sergei matheran who was
also recruited by the FBI he was at one
point he was entrapped by the FBI when
he he tried to buy a stereo equipment I
know in Washington store and the FBI had
the store owner offer my Turin to
exchange cases of vodka because it
couldn't afford to buy it with with
dollars and this is just one of the
schemes that the FBI used to try to put
pressure on him to to work work for the
work for the United States to engage in
any kind of private enterprise like that
which is the Russians called speculation
was illegal and you could certainly lose
your job because of it that is Viktor
with his wife and daughter that is
Viktor with his wife and daughter at
Niagara Falls they much enjoy travelling
around the United States and they said
they liked Americans a lot and they they
thought the United States was beautiful
and they tried to get out as as much as
they could
that is Ronald Reagan shaking the hands
of alia Gordievsky in the middle is FBI
special agent David major sorry that is
wrong Reagan shaking the hand of onion
Gordievsky being introduced by David
major who was a an FBI special agent
Gordievsky was the head of the KGB
station in London and it was for a long
time he was thought to have been
betrayed by Ames in 1985 and when the
KGB learned that he was a he was a
British agent he was recalled to Moscow
ostensibly to receive a formally receive
his promotion he'd been promoted and
they told him that he had to come back
to to sit in a ceremony in fact after he
got back he saw that his apartment had
been searched he was taken to a KGB safe
house in the country he was interrogated
drugged but he didn't confess and the
KGB didn't have hard evidence on him
so it let him go he was allowed to go
back to his apartment but kept under
strict surveillance and ended up
escaping from under the KGB's nose and
made his way to the Finnish border where
British intelligence officers smuggled
him across the border in the trunk of a
car wrapped in thermal blankets one of
the revelations in the book is that he
was a Gordievsky was actually betrayed
by a British journalist in 1985 who
telephoned Viktor and tipped him off
that's Robert Hanssen whom Victor never
met I didn't know his name I only found
that out in 2001 when he was arrested
that is hundred dollar bills amounting
to fifty thousand dollars left for
Hanson by the KGB under a footbridge in
a Virginia Park analyst was recovered by
the FBI in 2001
this is Vitaly Yurchenko in 1985 he was
the highest ranking KGB officer to
defect the Americans he spent some time
being debriefed by the CIA in the FBI
and some ones later he read affected so
to speak to the Soviet Union and at the
time it wasn't clear whether he was
planted by the KGB to provide
disinformation or whether he had been
become just discouraged and decided to
go back home but he helped the KGB play
in game that kept the CIA guessing for
many years and actually helped to
protect the identity of Ames because it
deflected suspicion away from him
that's the entrance of the Soviet
embassy compound in Washington where
your chin has showed up after leaving a
se a guard watching him and the he that
the guard was it was on a weekend and he
was guarded by a junior officer and
Europe have convinced him to take him
for a drive they went to a shopping mall
and then to a Georgetown restaurant
where you should go
got up and walked away and showed up
with these gates 20 minutes later Victor
was wasn't there he was at it was it he
was at home but he was called in and
minutes later he was debriefing your
chinko this is the first page of a nine
page note from the KGB to Ames sent to
him in June 1989 this is a note from
Ames to the KGB that was recovered from
his garbage and pieced together by the
FBI and stated September 1993
this is a dead drop site for Aldrich
Ames in in a park in Bethesda Maryland
this is where materials were exchanged
money left for Ames and where Ames would
leave documents and other things for the
KGB this is a photo of FBI agents
arrested Ames on February 21st 1994 this
is KGB chairman vadim bahattin
Russian president Boris Yeltsin
appointed a head of the KGB and was a
relative liberal and helped spearhead
the dismantling of the KGB after the
Soviet collapse
he's almost universally hated by most
former KGB officers this is a picture of
victors in the middle sitting by the
table and it's these are Victor's
employees for his security company
Victor now runs a private security
company in Moscow called alpha Puma and
the other people who worked with him
this is a picture of Victor his wife and
at the marriage of his daughter in in
California his daughter studied at the
Monterey Language Institute in
California met an American fell in love
and got married they now live in Moscow
and their grandson is almost inseparable
from from Victor these days this is a
picture of on the far left that is Milt
Bearden was the former head of the
Soviet and East European division of the
CIA essentially the cave one of the
KGB's worst adversaries Victor's just to
the right of him and to the right of
Victor is the initial version his
colleague from India who was KGB
chairman for a day we don't know that
the last person was I'm not entirely
sure Milt was writing writing a book and
making trips to to Russia and met met
Victor they've conducted interviews so I
must have been during one of those trips
this is a photo this is the inside the
office of Vladimir Khrushchev who's on
the far right and it's a meeting with
Czech intelligence officers
this is a statement from 1989 from the
KGB to Ames listing how much money had
been paid how much money had been set
aside for him apparently in a Moscow
bank account this is in the Middle East
dinosaur fund rusev
the former head of the KGB station in
Washington Victor's boss with on his
left is his wife and on the on the right
with her with her back toward us is
Victor's wife this is at and Russo's da
Cho country house outside of Moscow in a
plot where a lot of former KGB officers
and current intelligence officers have
their - as it was allocated in this plot
obviously by the state and a lot of
retired KGB officers are still quite
friendly and see each other quite often
I think that's it
[Music]
my own I guess I am on what will be
revealed later we have time for a few
questions if anyone has any yes right
over here sometimes it seemed better to
consider not exposing them because of
the embarrassment factor I also want to
know if money is a primary motive that
seems to be where the agency would focus
most of its scrutiny and monitoring
they're looking for bank accounts or
large expenditures but it seems like
sometimes his expenditures only seem
obvious after the path we should
probably repeat with the absence of
microphones question first of all about
the notion of whether audit was ever
expedient to let us buy keep spying to
avoid the embarrassment of discovery
absolutely right and when when an agent
was was uncovered when a mole was
uncovered inside an agency there were
several options one of them is to let
him stay there and try to isolate for
him from any kind of sensitive
information in order to either pass on
disinformation or to protect one's own
agent if if a CIA mole inside the KGB is
arrested that immediately would would
make the KGB know I'm sorry if a KGB
mole inside the CIA is arrested by the
KGB the CIA would think well where did
he get this information so there were a
number of options another option would
be to try to get this try to get this
agent to become a double agent
essentially to continue working and pass
on disinformation about the money I'm so
the money the question of how frequently
money was the principal motive for
selling out no the question was was do
they live that's difficult that mean
it's difficult to say certainly
you're quite right after the fact this
is what happened with Ames the story
from the FBI was that he was caught in a
mole hunt one of many where it was it
was apparent that he was spending far
too much money for his for his salary he
bought a new house he had a Jaguar he
was wearing expensive suits all of a
sudden he redid his teeth and the fact
is though that Ames was betrayed by a
defector from well from Russia was in
after the fall of the Soviet Union but
he was essentially betrayed by an agent
and this is a point that Victor and many
intelligence officers make that spies
betrayed spies it's very difficult to
find agents moles in your own
organization even if they're out there
spending a tremendous amount of money
because they're possibly thousands of
people who could fit this fits
description and so in a lot of cases the
story that that a mole was caught
because of the money who was spending is
fabricated after the fact precisely to
cover up for the real source of the
information yes well right Ames Ames was
a walk-in Hanson wasn't walking as well
technically Victor recruited them
because he was there signing them up so
he gets credit for that read what's in
the book actually Victor plays him very
well and winds up actually getting Ames
to be a lot more and admitting a lot
more than Ames attended to I think that
that the Turkish and rightfully deserves
credit for more than just being there
well that's that's true but another
point is that the Victor and
and many intelligence officers on both
sides of the the Cold War spy games say
is that it's almost impossible are very
difficult to try to convince somebody to
spy who doesn't want to spy essentially
finding good agents is a process of
seeking out people who already want to
commit espionage and it's not even that
simple because well certainly they're
probably quite a few people who would
want to spy who neither have access to
information that would make it worth it
for the KGB to expend the money in the
effort and go through the risk of
running an agent but also to have the
ability to pass over this information so
you need these at least these three
variables and lining them up is
incredibly difficult and agents who are
coerced into spying were blackmailed or
otherwise convinced that it would be
better for them to spy once the AAA
officer told me that those kinds of
agents every time you meet them you have
to reroute them so most agents good
agents are walkins quite right in both
intelligence communities how did Ames
have
that kind of information that he could
just build that yeah he was he was the
head of counterintelligence in the
Soviet and East European division in the
CIA so he had access to a tremendous
amount of information
another of the accepted facts
interpretations of Ames's careers that
he was a mediocre officer he drank a lot
and certainly there there are facts to
to prove that but he can't have been and
this is a point that Victor makes he
can't have been as mediocre as he said
to be he was given important agents to
handle he had access to highly
classified information and he made the
decision to pass it along of this lady
right here one of the signs of someone
who wants to spy Wow well I think that
probably the biggest sign is potential
agent actually approaching the other
side I don't know how else you do it
other than perhaps working on somebody
and finding this person is willing to
spy sometimes it happened just by chance
you look at it over here yes sir
yes what kind of approval did cherkessia
need well actually
none this is his his memoir he doesn't
it's not written from documents or any
trawling of the of the archives in in
Moscow
so essentially he's giving his
interpretation of his 40 years in the
KGB one of the reasons that I think that
Viktor took the decision to write the
book was that after his after his return
to Moscow in 1986 after he scored these
stunning successes having signed up aims
and Hansen a year later he went back to
Moscow and instead of receiving great
congratulations he was essentially
shunted out of the service one of the
reasons was as I described during the
the slide show was that he knew a lot
he knew how Latin America which Gulf
will became KGB chairman had become KGB
chairman and of course which Gulf didn't
appreciate this and so Viktor was was
sidelined there was also the natural
what perhaps not natural but a common
mistrust envy of staff officers in
Moscow
toward field officers who were coming
back from the West or wherever they were
posted in the world and got to see a bit
of the bit of the globe so Viktor was
shunted out of the service in 1986
retired in 1991 after the coup and
essentially brushed brushed aside and
several years after Ames's exposure and
arrest in 1994 a top ranking KGB officer
actually accused Viktor of betraying
aims Viktor went to court 1 1 when the
suit cleared his name but it was a
series of steps that that I think Victor
went through to to make the decision to
write the book now it hasn't he didn't
clear it with anyone and we'll see what
the reaction is back in Moscow I guess
we will
yes this gentleman here yes I think so
Hanson has a actually worse than then
Eames he's locked up in so-called
Supermax conditions
I guess he's underground concei no one
gets no reading material and never sees
never sees daylight Eames has a little a
little better but yes how does the
compare in terms of damage done that
wasn't a direct subject of your book and
my thoughts on that well I I don't think
he I mean again III didn't do any
research and into Pollard he spied for
for Israel so so you know Victor Victor
doesn't you know couldn't couldn't say
that I don't know I don't I mean it was
a call celebrit was a big it was a big
stink and certainly there's a lot of
press about it so we read a lot about
Pollard I don't think he compares to to
Ames and Hanson but I couldn't give you
the different answer about then back
here yes sir voice in a piece of writing
[Applause]
well I was working as a Moscow
correspondent and I was approached by
Victor's literary agency
I met Victor we got on we decided that
he had a good story to tell and work
went ahead I enjoyed working with him
quite a lot it was a very easy process
that's not always the case it's actually
probably quite rarely the case but it
was a real collaborative effort
Victor wrote
extensive notes about his about his life
which I studied and came up with a
series of questions and ideas for the
book we then conducted a series of
interviews and I wrote the book based on
these interviews he read the drafts as I
was writing them of the chapters so it
was a real collaborative effort and
really I I hope I hope I believe that
this is this is Victor's voice I did
some independent research I interviewed
other KGB former KGB officers and CIA
and FBI officers as well but really my
role was trying to present Victor's
voice to an American audience and it's
my belief that really that that's that
the victors voices is preserved in the
book and this is his story that he's
telling over here yes that is a good
question where do they continue now well
one of the reasons is that they're the
wheels were the wheels are in motion
that and it's very difficult to stop
them I mean what potato chip okay I
think that relations between the United
States and Russia will probably get
worse soon Russia is now undergoing a
political backlash under President
Vladimir Putin the intelligence agencies
are now becoming increasingly important
in the daily running of the state
certainly Putin has appointed many of
his KGB colleagues in in a raft of state
and private enterprises and agencies in
Russia I you know Victor says this many
people say this that espionage is it's
almost an eternal thing it never goes
away governments will always try to seek
out information to make political
decisions Russia now feels that Russia
there's a tremendous amount of envy
towards the United States as the solar
superpower and so Russia really I think
believes that the United States at least
it feels a certain amount of antagonism
still an envy if not you know if not
outright opposition will have time for
that one final question the gentleman
right back here President Putin to the
people whose pictures you showed well
Putin was a relatively junior officer he
was stationed in East Germany and he was
much younger than and these than these
KGB officers but I so he doesn't I mean
he that he doesn't know them they didn't
have direct contact as far as I know and
despite the fact that Putin has
appointed a lot of his KGB cronies into
government in Russia a lot of the
officers retired officers to whom I
spoke really dislike Putin they believe
that he was placed there in the
presidency by the the entourage of
former president Boris Yeltsin to
protect their interests after his two
terms in office were up so there's a lot
of resentment to Putin and a lot of
former KGB officers think that he's
basically in it to protect a an
oligarchy a sort of a cabal of
industrialists and politicians there
will be now a signing of the books by
handler by mr. Fifer and I understand
there are some assigned plates from mr.
chair cassian and we thank you for
coming tonight